[Musique]
avec Julien Chida bonjour Julien bonjour
Pauline à la Une de cette revue de
presse un sujet qui fait les gros titres
c'est la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar qui n'en finit plus de faire débat
elle commence dimanche et on parle pas
toujours de sport effectivement
impossible de ne pas parler de ce sujet
avec cette coupe du monde qui commence
donc dimanche 5 milliards de
téléspectateurs attendus pour l'un des
événements sportifs les plus regardés
dans le monde d'ordinaire à l'approche
d'un événement comme celui-ci il y a de
l'attente de la ferveur de l'envie et
bien nous divin l'ambiance sur place
c'est ambiance aride adoa pas seulement
à cause du climax extrêmement chaud de
la péninsule de cette presqu'île de
commande du Qatar mais aussi parce que
tout simplement la ferveur un n'y est
pas on va regarder aussi du côté de
l'humanité qui nous parle ici je vous
agrandis ça d'une fête impossible
pourquoi une fête impossible tout
simplement à cause des soupçons de
corruption qui minent cette coupe du
monde sur comment cette Coupe du Monde a
été attribuée au Qatar en 2010 et aussi
soupçon de
ces ouvriers ces milliers d'ouvriers qui
sont morts sur les chantiers tout cela
fait que l'humanité parle d'une fête
impossible impossible de faire la fête
sur des sur des morts suspects nous dit
le journal autre sondage de la part de
la presse britannique je vais vous
montrer un exemple avec le Garden weekly
qui nous fait un jeu de mots sur cette
une avec un ballon crevé sur une sur une
une de sable et ce jeu de mots fear we
go ok on y va mais on y va à reculons la
croix résume tout cela on a un mot dans
sa dans sa Une en parlant de mondial de
la polémique avec ce dessin qui est
assez sympathique je trouve ce dessin de
de lignes avec un supporter partager
entre deux anges entre d'un côté l'un
qui lui dit allez une coupe du monde
c'est tous les quatre ans on s'en fiche
du contexte et l'autre qui lui dit pense
à l'environnement quand même et surtout
surtout au droit de l'homme on souhaite
bon courage à tous les fans de foot
rassurez-moi quand même la presse parle
bien un petit peu de sport oui en
quelque sorte Pauline regardez cette
ligne du magazine So Foot qui nous
propose le meilleur guide de la pire
Coupe du monde avec oui c'est assez bien
trouvé
avec des états des effectifs actuels
l'enjeu sportif et surtout le contexte
politique extrêmement lourd le magazine
nous promet je vous l'agrandis ici une
drôle de lecture de 168 pages bon pour
parler de sport il faut toujours
regarder l'un des titres phares de la
presse française l'équipe qui nous parle
une équipe de France toujours pas
d'attaque donc on y est toujours pas ça
c'est ça c'est clair au moins pour
l'équipe et si on regarde un petit peu
de plus près dans Libération libération
nous parle d'une équipe de France à
l'ambiance plombée je ne parle pas des
sourires crispés qu'il y a sur la photo
officielle mais bien de tension dans le
vestiaire entre les différentes stars de
l'équipe tension avec la Fédération une
ambiance plombée malgré leur statut de
champion du monde c'est à peu près le
même climat qu'il y avait avant la Coupe
du monde de 1998 on connaît tous la
suite oui alors écoutez on verra bien en
tout cas on va aller direction les
États-Unis à présent même si on souhaite
bien sûr plein de chances au bleu aux
États-Unis puisque la démocrate
d'anticiper renonce à devenir chef de
fil des démocrates au Congrès c'est une
page de la politique américaine qui se
tourne effectivement de ces deux
décennies de la politique américaine qui
se tournent avec une chambre des
représentants désormais sous pavillon
républicains Nancy Pelosi aurait pu
garder un rôle de chef de file de la
démocrates à la décider de ne pas
accepter ce poste il faut laisser place
à une nouvelle génération dit-elle
l'occasion pour le New York Times de
retracer le parcours de cette femme
politique américaine parcours hors norme
avec ce titre que j'aime beaucoup dans
le site de Pelosi badass là il y a pas
besoin de le traduire et cette photo
assez bien trouvée elle termine au
firmaments de sa carrière politique à 92
ans 82 ans après avoir été longtemps la
première opposante à l'ancien président
Donald Trump autre hommage celui du
Washington Post qui rend hommage donc à
une femme qui a réussi à se faire une
place au milieu d'un monde d'homme
milieu machiste décrit le journal et ça
pour l'illustrer je vous montre une
seule photo qui date de la présidence de
Donald Trump avec une Nancy Pelosi qui
tient tête face à une table remplie
d'homme donc c'est la seule femme sur la
photo face à un Donald Trump qui
justement on le sait avait un caractère
plutôt affirmé Nancy bellosy qui disait
à l'attention des jeunes filles Sky et
de limites la seule limite à vos
ambitions c'est le ciel avec elle
déclaré la tension de toutes les petites
filles américaines on prend la direction
du Royaume-Uni où le nouveau Premier
ministre ricciunac a présenté un nouveau
plan budgétaire qui peine à convaincre
oui il faut dire que la presque
britannique est assez unanime sur la
question et elle tire à boulerouge sur
cette nouvelle proposition de loi
budgétaire regardez le independent
plutôt classé à gauche qui nous parle
d'années sombre qui attendent les
Britanniques autre son de cloche cette
fois-ci du Times qui pour le coup est
conservateur est plutôt fidèle aux
parties de droite qui est au pouvoir lui
aussi nous parle d'année de d'année
d'imposition douloureuse pour les
Britanniques en vue des cinq prochaines
années à venir pourquoi ce titre est
bien tout simplement parce que le
gouvernement a annoncé des hausses
disposition pour les cinq prochaines
années à venir et aussi une baisse
drastique des dépenses budgétaires cela
fait suite à au plan au mini budget que
ni stress avait présenté il y a deux
mois en septembre qui avait provoqué une
chute de la livre sterling le dailyreur
n'y va pas par quatre chemins nous parle
de carnage tout simplement voilà là au
moins ça c'est clair ensuite on a pour
terminer une une du gardien qui nous dit
que et bien deux mois après justement ce
mini budget présenté par listrolls le
gouvernement fait de Pierre empire et
dit être impatient des prochaines
d'études de la tenue des prochaines
élections qui auront lieu au plus tard
fin 2024 et un peu de légèreté avant de
nous quitter loin du tumulte du monde
vous nous donnez les secrets du
bien-être oui en voici au moins un que
nous donne la croix et bien les
bienfaits de la nuit noire qui est un
bien commun occulter pourquoi tout
simplement à cause de la pollution
lumineuse pour nous qui vivons en
majorité en tout cas en France dans des
zones
urbaines ou du coup la nuit est occultée
par cette pollution lumineuse il faut
savoir nous dit la croix que la nuit
nous permet de mieux gérer notre notre
comment dire notre notre organisme tout
simplement et puisqu'on parle de
pollution lumineuse et surtout de nuit
je vous invite à regarder cette dernière
photo merveille une petite merveille du
télescope James web qui a été dévoilé
hier par la NASA alors je sais pas si
vous le voyez ça se passe ici donc c'est
à peu près par là au confins de
l'univers c'est tout simplement la photo
de la plus ancienne et lointaine galaxie
jamais prise par un télescope ça se
situe environ 13 milliards d'anniverses
de l'univers pardon c'est à dire au
confins de notre univers connu merci
beaucoup Julien pour cette revue de
presse